thank you
[Music]
there's a high school teacher in Bolivia
she was molesting somebody oh my God
that's what you want this to be that's
what it always is that's the JK [ __ ]
formula not not when I'm hosting don't
brand us the formula if there's a
teacher molestation I'm not yeah no
you're not gonna with me it's like
sexual assault doesn't exist oh that's
cool I don't pick those articles
all right it's a high school sex ed
teacher in Bolivia oh okay getting
warmer getting warmer getting warm she's
facing termination right now because
assumption something she did was she
Bolivia's
you did
[Music]
Define that word right now how do you
think of this she's so Bolivia's dude
in a Bolivian
that's amazing
all right so she assigned she assigned
homework to the male students in her
class what do you think she asked him to
do go home and [ __ ] a cow that's what
they do in Bolivia go home and like play
with yourself yeah probably play with
yourself so you get to know your Anatomy
or whatever kind of close get more
specific though oh finger yourself in a
butthole she wanted them to bring
something to class for the next day
students of the class to bring a condom
filled with their come oh dude I called
it tie off your condom bro so what was
her reason so that she could [ __ ] IV
that [ __ ] so they could look at it baby
and this is her reasoning okay it's not
gonna make sense but her reason is that
she wanted to illustrate and like uh
teach the class how long sperm can like
survive outside of your body that's a
pretty cool in order to tell girls like
hey like be you still have to be careful
even if the [ __ ] is on a different thing
so it's like if you're getting a pearl
necklace and he's busting on your chest
ladies be careful that [ __ ] is still
it's still live around it's active yeah
that was her like lesson plan she
couldn't just [ __ ] said that she
could have just said that instead of
bring your comes I'm gonna but how was
she gonna even prove that it's still
alive we don't know because it didn't
get that far and now suddenly every
guy's got to think to himself let me
bust in this condom and then I gotta
like tie it and [ __ ] put it in a
Ziploc bag like what the [ __ ] what's the
way that she was expecting it to happen
no then you cut you cut the condom and
then you get the little slide the
microscope slide you take the little
give me a little Petri stuff oh yeah
yeah and then you put on the slide you
put the other one on top of the
microscope and then you look but you
gotta first get the little like turkey
turkey juicer and the baster the mini
baster and is it even sanitary like they
don't even know how to do it right
you're just going to school with a bag
of [ __ ] come yeah literally and it's
weird because like it's only homework
for the guys so it's like I think I
would be more mad about that but it's
okay it's so sexist you guys okay you
know what though I'll be like what the
girls don't get any homework you know
when you do that as a kid that's a sweet
assignment that's the first place your
mind no the girls have work they have to
help the guys yeah group project Lab
Partners Lab Partners good teacher
you're a good teacher dude equal
opportunity uh man I don't know you know
what would be homework like great
homework the guy has to help the girl so
they know how to make them come oh
cool hey just
I hope we get to choose sir and we don't
get randomly assigned yo okay what would
that happen if you were in high school
if you were in high school and your sex
ed teacher did say all right guys this
is the homework don't [ __ ] tell
anybody I want you to just pick a
partner and just make them come oh and
then do a full report and keep your
mouth shut God damn it would you guys do
it or would you go Mom I'd get the worst
luck because I always came late to class
so all the groups would be paired up and
I'd be sitting there and I'd get like
the [ __ ] I would get the teacher I
don't have a partner Joe I'd get the guy
that didn't get picked yeah there's 16
boys and 14 girls in the class and I I
get the dude that didn't get picked and
it's like I guess you're my partner dude
meanwhile he's putting on latex gloves
like this [ __ ] well yeah you might have
the softest hands would you guys rat
your teacher out hell no nah I like cool
teachers
I'm not gonna say a [ __ ] word
remember I told you about my sex ed
teacher in Cypress College
there was like a sex ed teacher who's
like a white lady she was very old but
kind of looked like a MILF porn star for
like Elder porn Okay and then she she
would always like uh first day of school
right she would said she said uh you
know if you guys just want to start
jerking it in the middle class I really
have no opposition to that and then
everyone laughed we were like Ah that's
funny uh funny teacher and then the next
day she said it again and she was like
guys again if you guys feel compelled to
you know just have an orgasm in the
middle class
and then like less people would laugh
every day she said that and then finally
only she was saying it and then no one
left and we were just like she just
wants to see our dicks this is crazy and
then she would always remind us when
office hours was and like stuff like
that wow we were like dude this is wild
but nobody took her up on him because
you know
she's a little older somebody somebody
had to yeah or everybody was and just
lying about it yeah I wouldn't do that
works every three semesters makes the
teachers do some wild [ __ ] man I had a
Drama teacher at UCLA that was pretty
crazy
like she would just like so she was like
this older like white lady and then she
would as she's like talking about the
class with her she would just start
[ __ ] walking around the classroom and
then she would just like go like like
sit in like like students laps and like
and then she'll just start talking about
the syllabus she was like
oh you guys understand what the project
is
just like crazy [ __ ] like that I could I
could almost understand how that might
but you also kind of go I understand
kind of understand like it's in the
scope of this art or create yeah if it
was a math teacher I'd be like there's a
problem here yeah yeah so for that it's
like how much is that is is for her
pleasure yeah and how much of that is
actually getting people used to like
this environment being comfortable like
on a stage or something you know
you know what I'm talking about you
where you you know this DVD no I only
know that because I remember like in
early 2000s I remember like your friends
were [ __ ] joking about this DVD okay
so basically we had we had a class at
UCI called sociology 69 right social 69
it's it's like basically real mature or
UCI or actual sex class right but it was
in one of those [ __ ] Auditorium like
a big Hall it's a huge class everybody
as an elective like people always want
to take it because it's just really fun
right yeah super easy and then one of
the weeks out of this 10-week course
they have like spankies uh come in to
like display like toys and like DVDs and
stuff and just talk about the adult
industry
sponsored by them me and my homies from
from [ __ ] cadc we're always in the
back just like sleeping and [ __ ] right
because we always have like rehearsal
and stuff and then I remember Spanky's
comes in and then suddenly they're like
we're gonna get our free DVDs so they
start chucking these DVDs and I'm
literally like [ __ ] halfway past on
the back and one and way in the back
like that last row and this thing just
hits me in the chest oh [ __ ] right and I
pick it up and it's just right on the
corner right it's cracking up because he
knows what I'm talking about and it's
[ __ ] it's called it says all pissed
off Volume 14 and it's just girls just
[ __ ] peeing everywhere [ __ ] all
pissed off
today that's wild now as as college kids
though you know like this is great this
is like this is not Jack on the show but
this is great party material so we for
sure brought it home and I swear to God
that's why he's cracking up almost like
every other party just in the middle of
a party when it would get like really
people are just drunk and Randomness is
going on suddenly the TV would turn on
and just people would be being all
pissed off volume four four or fourteen
I remember what it was wait so are they
peeing it's literally just like old
school porno stuff like cameras like
slowly coming in and somebody's just
like getting ready to urinate and then
they're literally just like open them to
themselves and just like oh it's just a
girl chugging all kinds of water
this every scene is people just peeing
everywhere what if all the giveaway DVDs
are the ones they couldn't sell yeah so
that's why they're just like you get
[ __ ] Mick sucking you get peeing you
get Cocker and so it was like oh I want
the caca one one
oh yeah executive producer yeah I just
remembered I remember the cover so well
because that ended up in one of the
houses I lived in like uh I just saw it
and then it was it's like you know those
like low rider models that just have
their ass to the camera like this and
they're squatting it was that but just
hella piss coming out oh my God it was
the cover and I was like was it like
yellow what is this yeah it was like
real piss oh man that's funny and for
context that's just to catch up me and
Ryan
um we had like when I was living in one
house basically all those roommates they
ended up living with Ryan the next year
at the next house but I I graduated
um so like they we inherited the DVD
collection
school right we had the same like circle
like the circle of friends like a Venn
diagram so then the dorm situation it
was just houses that we were all like
renting rooms yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're connected by all pissed off I
haven't thought of that in like like
decades I haven't thought of it so I was
like do you remember all this just
remember everyone was laughing because
they were like there's 14 of these
possibly more possibly more because for
sure more dude yeah they've won every
six months EP is R Kelly dude is very
successful
[Music]
[Music]